la ville des ménules a habillé son parc
élégamment pour ce mois de juin cette
commune rurale dés Yvelines accueille
cette année 21 photographes de 13 pays
différents à l'occasion du festival Les
ménographies mais à la suite des
différents confinements il a pour
objectif de rendre accessible et
démocratiser le médium de la
photographie toutes les photos on a de
la photo partout sur tous nos téléphones
toutes nos applications toutes les
publicités qu'on voit qu'on croise son
photo mais du coup on l'imagine pas
comme un media marktistique et c'est un
peu injuste parce que c'est non
seulement un médium artistique mais
aussi à travers ce médias artistique
informatif et il doit être accessible à
tous c'est vraiment l'idée que n'importe
quelle personne n'importe quel niveau
social avec n'importe quelle éducation
puisse passer la porte du parc et passer
un bon moment et découvrir des choses
qui vont lui plaire c'est toujours le
problème de l'art visuel c'est de faire
venir le public parce que tout le monde
va pas au musée ou au moins ici ça
permet à une connexion peut-être avec le
public et puis
à l'extérieur c'est toujours chouette
les photographes ont été choisies par
sélection et appels à candidature cette
année le festival s'articule autour de
trois thématiques phares la maternité
l'environnement et le genre des thèmes
actuels abordés à travers différents
regards et qui traduisent beaucoup
d'enjeux sociétaux contemporains c'est
très important pour moi de montrer la
fragilité du monde la fragilité de la
nature le côté éphémère des fleurs
c'est-à-dire que les saisons le
printemps l'été l'automne ou les fleurs
ont une durée de vie beaucoup plus
courte que l'être humain et il faut en
profiter et c'était très important pour
moi de montrer ses fleurs qui ont vécu
qui sont sur le sol que j'ai ramassé et
je redonne une seconde existence en le
prenant en photo ma mère la source est
un projet qui rend hommage à mes
origines méditerranéennes et aux femmes
de ma famille et c'est un projet qui
parle de la filiation matrilinéaire et
de et de transmission au sein d'une
famille par les femmes une série que
j'ai commencé à un an et demi et qui est
né de la volonté de faire le portrait de
d'amis et
personne de mon entourage qui se pose
des questions sur leur genre et sur leur
identité et pas parce que j'en avais
envie d'en faire un sujet mais parce que
mes amis et mes proches sont dans ces
questionnements cette balade artistique
se poursuit dans d'autres communes des
Yvelines des photographies sont exposées
à la queue les Yvelines à la chapelle de
Clairefontaine ou encore à la Maison
Louis Carré de Bazoches-sur-Guyonne
l'exposition est accessible gratuitement
jusqu'au 25 juin prochain